a lot of your videos are you going out
to giving money to people random people
but people who demonstrate kindness and
generosity yeah
one of my favorite things to do man is
just bless people whether they're
they're low income middle-income or
super wealthy sometimes you could be in
a coffee line by the guy behind you
that's a billionaire five dollar cup of
coffee and it might look like the
dumbest thing in the world but maybe
that five dollar cup of coffee is the
one thing that will unlock compassion in
his heart and he's never had someone
give him something without asking for
something and now he's gonna go out on
his own and donate a hundred thousand
dollars a month to helping people out
you know so really not judging anyone no
matter what income level they are or
what they do